Islam has a system of hijab,
modesty.
People normally talk about hijab for the
woman. Allah subhanana wa ta'ala in the
Quran first talks about the hijab for
the man and then for the woman.
Allah says in surah N chapter number 24
verse number 30. Say to the believing
man that he should lower his gaze and
guard his modesty.
That means whenever a man looks at a
woman, any brazen thought comes, he
should lower his case.
Once there was a young Muslim who was
staring at a girl for a long time. I
SAID, "BRETHREN, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
IT'S NOT ALLOWED IN ISLAM." He told me,
"Our beloved prophet said, the first
glance is forgiven. The second is
prohibited. I have not completed half my
glance."
What did the prophet mean? The first
glance is forgiven. The second is
probability. That means if
unintentionally look at a woman, don't
look at her, stare at her again to feast
on a beauty. That does not mean you can
look at a woman without blinking for 10
minutes and saying, "I'm not complete my
glance."
The next verse speaks about hijab for
the woman. In surah Nur chapter number
24 verse number 31 Allah says say to the
believing woman that she should lower a
g and guard a modesty and display not a
beauty except what appears ordinarily of
and draw a head covering over a bosom
except in front of her husband her
father her son and a big list of meam
the close relatives who she cannot marry
is given.
There are basically six major criteria
for hijab mentioned in the Quran and the
sai had
the first is the extent. That's the only
criteria that differs between the male
and the female. For the man it is from
the navl to the knee.
That's the other extent. For the woman
the complete body should be covered. The
only part that can be seen are the hands
up to the wrist and the face. But some
scholars say even this should be
covered. the difference of opinion.
The second criteria, the clothes they
wear, it should not be transparent or
translucent so that you can see through.
[snorts]
Point number three, it should not be so
tight fitting so that you so it reveals
the figure.
Number four, it should not be so
glamorous so that it attracts the
opposite sex.
Number five, it should not resemble that
of the unbeliever. You can't wear a
cross which is a sign of Christianity.
You can't put a tika vermul on which
sign of Hinduism. And the sixth is you
should not wear clothes that of the
opposite sex. Women should not wear
clothes that of the man. Man should not
wear clothes that of woman.
These are the basic six criteria for
hijab.
After this, [snorts]
first hijab for the man, lower his case,
then for the woman. After this, the
Islamic Sharia says if any man rapes any
woman, capital punishment, death
penalty. People say death penalty IN
THIS AGE OF 21ST CENTURY. Islam is a
barbaric religion. It's a ruthless
religion.
But when I ask this question to the
non-Muslims and I've asked this many
times that hypothetically if someone
rapes your mother
and if the rapist is brought in front of
you what punishment to give all of them
said we will put him to death.
Some went to the extent of SAYING WE
WILL TORTURE HIM TO DEATH.
Why the double standard? Someone wants
to rape your mother, your daughter, you
want to put him to death. Someone raped
somebody else's daughter, you said that
penalty is a barbaric law.
There was one smart Alex in America when
I gone to America. YOU TOLD ME DR.
ZAKIR, I will give him imprisonment
for 7 years. So I said, do you know the
statistics of America?
Out of those people that are imprisoned
and when they are let free more than 90%
again raped. So you want your mother to
be raped again you are most welcome. I
don't want
this is the statistics. If you see the
statistics of America do you know one of
the country which has the highest rate
of rape is America USA.
according to the FBI statistics
of 1990.
I'm saying that because that time I
started giving lectures that I'll give
off today. 1990 according to FBI
statistics 102,555
cases of rape took place
and they said only 16% were reported.
Means if you want the full amount you
multiply by 16 you multiply by 6.25 25
that means 640,968
rape took place in 1990 alone that means
every 50 seconds one rape is taking
place
if you read the statistics of
US bureau justice of crime see both are
different the police always the
government always want to show there
less rape but the independent survey
shows more the other survey says that
every so if you Calculate it comes to
every 50 one rape. The other survey says
every 32 second one rape is taking
place.
If you see 2023 statistics
how many cases reported 142,000
more than 142,000 that means they got
bolder. It was 102,555.
Now it is 142,000 plus. In the few years
the American got more bold. And if you
calculate this new statistics of FBI, it
comes to close again 32 second wonder
you know I am here since the last about
more than an hour on the stage more than
one I'm for one or 10 minutes on the
stage
already
already more than 60 ribs may have taken
place since the time I'm on the stage
50 ribs
I'm asking In the question if you
implement the Islamic Sharia
that the man whenever he looks at a
woman any brazen thought comes he should
lower his gaze the woman the complete
body should be covered the only part
that can be seen are the face and hands
up to the wrist and after that if any
man rapes a woman capital punishment
death penalty I'm asking the question
will the rate of rape in USA will it
increase will it remain the same or will
decrease
you if decrease [laughter]
it's a practical law you implement the
sha and YOU GET RESULTS THAT'S THE
reason I say that Islam besides speaking
good things it shows you a way how to
achieve the state of goodness so if you
read the scriptures of the major world
religions you realize that all the
scriptures
basically say that you should believe
and worship worship only one God. That's
the different thing that people don't
read the scripture.
The religious leaders of many of
religion they misguide them. So if you
read the scripture yourself and
understand it, you'll realize that there
is only one God and he alone should be
worshiped.
If Christian means
following the teachings of Jesus Christ
peace be upon him,
the Muslims are more Christian than the
Christian themselves.
I'm going to give a talk in Tanzania
after about
on the 5th
of December similarities between Islam
and Christianity
and I've shown there that whatever Jesus
Christ peace be upon him preached if you
read the Bible we Muslims follow more of
the teachings of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him than the Christian themselves.
So Christian means a person who follows
the teachings of Jesus Christ peace be
upon him. We Muslims are more Christian
than the Christian themselves.
What is the meaning of Jew? Jew means a
person who loves God.
And alhamdulillah we Muslims love God.
[clears throat]
Islam means coming from the root word
salam which means peace.
It's also derived from the Arabic word
sil which means submitting your will to
almighty god. So Islam means peace
acquired by submitting to Almighty God.
So if you read the scriptures of the
major religions,
you can talk with your non-Muslim
friends and the Muslims and non-Muslims
can get together and agree to follow
what is common. The world will be a much
peaceful world.
I would like to end my speech by giving
by reciting the vers of the glorious
Quran of chapter number 103 verse number
1 to3 which says
by the token of time man is wearily in a
state of loss except those who have
faith
those who do righteous deed those who
exalt people to truth And those who
exhort people to patient pursuits.
[applause]